the Joe Rogan experience a lot of our
food comes from California yeah yeah the
farmland between here and San Francisco
is crazy
Republican go up there you see these you
know anti-abortion bill boards and pro
Trump billboards and oh my goodness it's
like a different world it's so crazy
because it's the world of the people who
have to work from [ __ ] dawn till like
7:00 p.m. and then they crash they go
back to the farm again they're always
trying to keep it together yeah [ __ ] man
when it comes to like farmers there's
one thing you get a lot of you get a lot
of religion and some I'm not it's not a
value judgment it's just but you get a
lot of religion and you get a lot of
Republicans you get a lot of that it's
not that common that you get a little
far there's certainly some organic
farmers that are like real progressive
liberal people they understand the
importance of growing your own food but
like mass farmers like when farmers are
growing corn to feed cows like that
those kind of farmers there's nothing
wrong with that they need them that
those [ __ ] are a lot of those people
are Republican and you got to wonder
like maybe it's just like the party of
the people that really bust their ass
and they they want that they want that
that hard-working farmer ethic is like
there's no room for [ __ ] in that
life if you got to get up at 6 o'clock
in the morning and feed the chickens and
milk the cows and then do [ __ ] all day
long and you're barely paying your bills
you don't want to hear any [ __ ] you
don't want to hear any [ __ ] and so I
think a lot of them are Republicans
because Republican stands for like
there's no [ __ ] perspective on life
that they think the Democrats want to
hand out their money and take too much
of the taxes but it's because of their
reality that's because the reality
that's particularly grueling occupation
these people have taken on you know it's
it's almost like a mistake of
perspective you know they don't they
don't have opportunity to see things
openly like see the whole world and see
where their their position is like they
have a uniquely difficult position they
might think the whole world is like that
but it's not necessarily like you just
chose something that's a preposterous
endeavor I mean
mean that in an admirable way I'm a good
miring farmer's work ethic if you took a
regular person's you or me who's never
worked like that ever and say hey Alan
you and Joe are gonna get up at five
o'clock in the morning you're gonna feed
the chickens and milk today man and
you're barely gonna make any money and
you're gonna have crazy loans and you're
gonna need to be sensitised by the
goddamn government
yep no manuals so much depression it's
suicide and when their farms collapse
man it's [ __ ] devastating and there's
some people who could do it too but some
people would do it and they become very
successful and some people do it and
love it and swear by it I mean there's a
whole spectrum but that that has got to
test you and if you think about how
crazy that is that that's not more
lucrative like what is more valuable to
us that are why do we treat them that
way exactly it's like what else is more
valuable our teachers who are so
valuable yes what a [ __ ] up society
back with what why does more value just
number one is stay alive yes number one
how do you do that you need for folk'
the v-league food yeah we should take so
beasts yes they should be take there's a
fruit they literally bring you fruit and
you give them paper and you get their
fruit and it sustains you but they're
struggling and then number two is
teachers know because once you here you
got to learn something what do you what
do we do it our teachers we take them we
pay them dog [ __ ] we stick them in front
of 50 kids barely paying attention and
you just hope to make an impact on like
I'm sure you have a few teachers like
that said a thing at one point time
you're like okay like this teachers do
make a difference yeah mr. friedenberg
you'll never you'll never be able to
draw a woman until you've had a woman oh
that's a Bill Withers line wow that
sounds like a song yeah mr. friedenberg
god damn yeah I had one guy who was a
Vietnam vet who was a heavy guy he was
heavy and he
in middle school when I was in I was in
the Mary Curley middle school and
Jamaica Jamaica plains which is at the
time it was a real sketchy neighborhood
outside of Boston suburb not a suburb of
Boston but you know inner-city we moved
there from Florida and that was the only
place we could afford when I was kid and
this is like 17 year old kids in my
seventh grade class was so ridiculous
I'm not exaggerating man yeah it was
maybe eighth grade I don't forget but
there was just one teacher anyway he was
a science teacher and he would grow his
own radishes and he kept saying like all
I need is radishes and salt and that's
my lunch and I grew my lunch and I'm not
thinking like wow this guy's out there
growing his lunch even out here in the
city but this is the big thing he said
to me he goes you ever want to hurt your
head he goes just go outside and look up
at space and realize how big it is
trying to imagine something that has no
end if you really want to hurt your
brain just try to imagine that space has
no end that [ __ ] me up dude I was like
13 yeah it's like oh my god he's right
what there's no end and I swear to God
that became a big part of this shift and
how I started viewing the world
[Applause]